en avait un qui était là-bas qui a fait
énormément parler c'est bernard montiel
qui suis énormément de critiques et il
ya marie et marie émilie phrasie qu'a
dit le dernier épisode de vidéo gag
bernard montiel dans le carré culture à
l'investiture des manuels macron la
culture avait un autre hymne niveau sous
françois 1er ce n'est pas en renommant
son parti renaissance qu'on arrive
forcément à la cheville de l'ancien roi
de france est là bernard montiel lui a
répondu toujours avec le tact qu'on lui
connaît
quelques audaces la fachos et mais
présentent pas étonnant je n'étais pas
dans le carré culture et je vous emmerde
avec plaisir la mariée emilie bouzar
répondu un moment qu'elle manque
d'élégance une divergence d'opinion
politique ne permet pas de tels propos
misogynes et ordurier rien d'étonnant de
la part d'un lâche qui supprime ces
tweets vous auriez mieux fait de rester
présentateur de vidéo gag apparemment
marié minimes et vidéo
haut doubs le porte parole du
rassemblement national aussi a réagi
ensuite à cet embrouillamini m bernard
montiel dans le cari culture c'est comme
exposé un rouleau de pq dans la galerie
des glaces du château de versailles
soutient marie et me dit insulté par ce
pauvre type beaucoup trop pays
est claire s'il ya un truc sur c'est
beaucoup trop perçu c'est ça c'est sûr
non juste bernard vous avez essuyées
énormément de critiques c'est vrai quoi
la mort ya plein de gens qui m'ont
appelé m'ont dit à ton pote bernard
montiel ton pot de match ni basse et
très bien mon pote barbares modèle qui
moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] son tournage
pas dole qui me fait chi donc voilà et
donc bernard vous comprenez les
critiques ou pas oui oui d'autant plus
je les comprends que ce je le fais
jamais je réponds jamais aux adultes ça
arrive souvent bon c'est bien fait d'y
aller ou pas vous regrettez vous pas
parce que ça dès que vous aimez italia
les investitures près du tout j'étais
très flatté d'être invités quand vous
êtes pas dit
c'est a comme pas mais parlait je m'en
fous ça fait trente
non non non non c'est pas ça ce que je
regrette simplement bon d'abord je
n'étais pas dans le car a culture julien
houle
culture peut-être
attendez un peu vous êtes mais pourquoi
j'ai plutôt aimable avec vous je
pourrais être moi facebook était
insultant vous aurez vous serez bientôt
dans le carré sûrement vip à la santé
avec tous les problèmes juridiques que
vous avez
des
cultures blé ministre a dans le carré
viiip la centrale je voulais dire j'ai
regretté évidemment ce tweet je ne
réponds jamais j'ai été où c'est
pourquoi en fait on est avec des potes
on rigolait et or me dis tiens t'as vu
ce qu'on a dit vidéo gag d'abord ça
mépris pour les gens qui regardent des
vidéos gags comme filippo d'ailleurs
puisqu'il l'a dit même ici j'avais plus
de 7 millions de téléspectateurs qui
regardaient cette émission donc respect
à eux oui mais je les en remercie mais
non c'est important donc voilà je veux
pas qu'on critique les gens qui ont aimé
cette émission comme moi voilà
maintenant le reste ça c'est habituel
chez eux dans leur merde il avait prié
et la seule est ce qu'un quiconque y
comprennent les critiques envers bernard
montiel qui soit les gilles verdez bien
sûr non je comprends pas ce que vous
êtes gilles verlant faire là-bas très
franchement je ne comprends pas
cette opinion ah oui je ne comprends pas
votre présence à bah moi ça m'a choqué
qu'êtes-vous bernard montiel pour être à
l'elysée non mais franchement je me suis
dit mais qu'est ce que cet uruguay
faty là ils ont à faire là bas j'ai pas
du tout compris mais alors ayez jamais
dû y aller parce que non mais vous
n'êtes pas les risibles les mêmes
ennuyeux pour vous quant à votre tweet
c'est pas digne de vous ne le souhaitez
pas bien c'est vrai alors y avait de la
marque qu'est ce que vous répondez à
gilles cellule échos pourquoi
c est qu il je connais par coeur gilles
non non moi je regarde pas dire et
pourquoi je serais pas allée pavée sony
je veux pas des jeux des gens qui
souhaitent qu'ils soient contre qui
disent voilà que parce que si c'est pour
dire oui il a eu raison d'y aller je
vais montrer sur dsk qui sont contre
n'ont maintenant qu'ils sont pas les
cris moi ça me choque pas bernard en
particulier mais toutes les
personnalités puisqu'au delà de leur
présence moi ce qui me choque un peu
c'est leur attitude ils sont tout
sourire ils font des courbettes on
dirait qu'ils font tout pour plaire à sa
majesté donc déjà ça ça me gêne et on
sait très bien ils vont pas faire la
gueule non mais on sait très bien que la
majorité de ces personnalités et je ne
parle patois bernard mais ne sont pas là
pour les beaux yeux du président ils
sont là parce qu'ils ont un petit
privilège par ci une petite subvention
par là et ça je pense que les gens le
savent et le vois et je trouve ça assez
gênant voilà un signal en fait d'entre
eux soit de privilèges de caste et je
trouve ça gênant alors il y avait les
deux théâtres représenter le privé et le
public et guillaume gallienne le côté à
christian hecq que personne assise près
personne l'a reconnu christian avec
quelques uns des plus grands comédiens
la comédie française et on peut quand
même dire qu'il ya un malaise quand les
gens lors ils se disent tous lui il a
fait ça à lui l'a fait si et quand c'est
toi sauf fx
s'est passée
la télévision ils savent même pas que
j'étais même pétition
si le ca mais personne ne les regarde on
sait même pas qui c'est dans foot ça
julien houle juste qu'est ce que vous
pensez vous de la preuve vous aimons
c'est le tweak qui vous a mené rousset
ou la présence de bernard montiel vous
comprenez pas annoncé les insultes
contre une jeune militante ca les jeunes
oui les jeunes d'une part d'une femme et
c'est vrai que vous avez fait preuve de
misogynie crasse il faut bien le dire
moi que vous alliez vous pavaner à la
cérémonie d'investiture des mails macron
c'est votre droit d'être un citoyen vous
avez le droit d'avoir une préférence
démocratique vous avez le droit de
soutenir même mâcon c'est votre droit le
plus strict invités lorsque je n'admets
pas celle insultes envers 13 millions
d'électeurs parce que quand vous traitez
non seulement dix ans ici ses traits à
lyon d'une excellente et excusez moi
quand vous traitez cette jeune militante
de kaunas quand vous dites je les
emmerde clairement vous insultez les
électeurs de marine le pen et tous ceux
qui ne pensent pas comme vous et c'est
ça que je reproche finalement à vous
mais à ce petit milieu d'acteurs de
chanteurs bien pensant qu'ils aillent à
la cérémonie très bien mais qu'ils
arrêtent d'insultés notamment lors d'une
tribune ils ont signé une tribune
pendant l'entre-deux-tours 500
signataires on a eu plus est on à jane
birkin tout ça qui traite nos électeurs
de xénophobe de raciste qui dénonce
notamment le fait qu'il soit attaché à
la priorité nationale alors que
eux-mêmes bénéficie dans leur métier
c'est le seul corps de métier qui
bénéficient de la priorité nationale
avec l'exception culturelle française il
touche un pognon de dingue mais il
refuse que les pauvres aussi profitent
de cette priorité nationale donc je
trouve ça déplacé voilà donc votre tweet
il et ordurier très clairement vous
n'aviez pas insulter c'est cette
militante à la raison donc il serait bon
ton de bon ton que vous lui présenter
des excuses tout simplement ce soit
alors c'est vrai comme elle s'appelle
marie émilie marie-émilie vous me
regardez
je vois que tu vas la pécho
je suis désolé et je les retire et pour
ça j'ai trouvé je réponds jamais aux
insultes là je les fais besoin était
dans une ambiance ça m'a énervé par
rapport à la vidéo gag dont je suis fier
et épique et vous si on vous rappelle
votre passé de mannequin mais j'en suis
très fier ouais c'est bien c'est très
fier mois la saison passée vous savez et
même aussi alors ça je dis vidéo
qu'accessible jetez pas contents qu'on
attaque vidéo gag en revanche je n'étais
pas dans le carré culture c'était dans
le carré ami de la famille mais qui
était juste à côté parce que j'étais
avec les soeurs de madame macron
d'accorder une pression on voit que vous
êtes mal à l'aise berne a alors rejeté
par ankara culture gp d'inde car
inquiets des amis de madame à ce cours
elle à l'aise du tout je précise
simplement les choses ensuite sur le
tweet vous rendez compte de votre erreur
vous avez fait partie des courtisans
maintenant vous êtes un courtisan à
l'aise bottes moi je suis déçu
les bottes par rapport à qui monte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fondée sociaux j'ai le grand dessus
c'est que du bon
non je voudrais dire je voudrais dire
c'est vous représentez par la france à
inviter un ami
mr on vous et moi c'est fini de le jouer
il vous dire qu'en plus j'ai la
sympathie pour vous je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vos idées mais j'ai la
sympathie pour vous je vous vois à peu
partout traîner d'ailleurs vous avez ces
gâteaux genre je suis là regardez moi je
suis là si vous êtes porte-parole azam
et réseaux vous avez fait tous les un
peu tous les partis jusqu'à trouver
votre place vous avez bien fait je vous
trouve sympathique en plus c'est marrant
jouant parfois chez morandini ok c'est à
dire alors on fait contre lui rien alors
à tout ça patine partout
juste injuste parce que le débat et
c'est sur ces artistes qui vont ou
investiture sa voix est ce que moi je
vous dirais hacker est ce que si vous
aviez été invités est ce que vous y
seriez ali adjas lassalvy où nous allons
moi non donc bien sûr que pourquoi parce
qu'on a une place à la télévision et que
quelque part affiché on sait qu'en
france a affiché son soutien pour un
parti politique ou pour une personne
c'est toujours risqué donc bernard c'est
très courageux mais en même temps c'est
un secret de polichinelle on sait qu'il
est proche du président voilà moi je
n'aurais pas fait absolument pas ce à
quoi je vais vous dire il y avait une
demande comme de madame macron je peux
vous dire c'est un petit secret elle ne
voulait pas les artistes elle ne voulait
pas parce qu'il ya eu tout un tas d'amis
qu'elle ferait s'intéressant à ce que
vous dites oui elle ne voulait ne
voulait pas qu'on les invite franchir
pour eux parce que pourrait leur porter
préjudice exactement madame la croquette
une femme extrêmement intégré et briand
bien elle m'a dit mais bernard je vais
inviter personnes je ne veux pas ceux
qui voudront venir viendront mais je
n'invite personnes dont il n'était pas
invité par exemple guillaume gallienne
on sait qu'ils sont intimes christian
avec alan cercle intime cluzet il est
venu et c'était un grand plaisir de
l'accueillir l'énergie sissoko que tu as
très grand metteur en scène était l'âme
c'est tout un il y avait mais les autres
les intimes que l'on connaît comme
arditi ou comme ou comme luchini tout ça
ou berléand on le sait qu'ils étaient à
la rotonde à l'époque et pas moi
d'ailleurs ils sont pas venus nami a
pris une différence je pense entre être
invité une cérémonie y aller et je pense
qu'on a le droit d'avoir une préférence
de dire qu'on préfère macron parce qu'on
est plus proche de ses idées on est des
citoyens et les acteurs et les artistes
ont des citoyens mais ensuite de
demander et de prendre parti ouvertement
et d'insulter les électeurs du camp
verse de dire qu'il faut signer une
tribune parce que ce serait le mal
absolu parce que maryse et locales elles
ont voulu décider mais c'est ça en fait
moi je pense rien dire est à leur place
ces gens là ils sont écoutés ils sont
regardés ils sont financés par des
français moi j'y croyais pas politique
mais bien sûr que oui monsieur vous vous
dites vous dites nous qui respecte
tellement ça n'a pas que vous dites
monsieur odoul je n'y crois pas moi
synthé pacte là dès que les que les
acteurs ou les autres artistes signent
des pétitions en faveur du président je
n'y crois pas à l'impact de ça je n'y
crois pas du tout voyez quoi ils le font
alors ils l'ont fait c'est leur problème
c'est qu'ils ont décidé ça n'est pas une
demande de l'elysée je n'y crois pas
d'impact non mais ils le font parce que
donc c'est tous ces gens là seront des
petits services entre amis et voilà je
pense qu'à glendale sont très bas non
mais je parle patois mais il ya des
annonces est vraiment emmanuel macron
sont réélus comme j'ai dis parce qu'ils
vont avoir une petite subvention pour un
film par ci un petit service rendu par
là s'est passé comme ça on joue tous ces
gens-là visa sur ce coup ci c'est bien
sûr bien n'arrivons jamais les gens là
vous le savez très bien c'est pas parce
que toi tu le fais tout le temps ici tu
vas la grippe
vous n'avez pas l'argument mais je vous
adore mais vous êtes gêné et vous avez
commis une erreur fondamentale
avec plus tôt
j'annonce que vous avez fait un bon
temps mais parce que vous êtes marquer
maintenant vous êtes identifié s'est
replié de tbc avant mais moi ça me gêne
moi je vous le dis à chaque fois que
monsieur affiche qu'est-ce qu'ils seront
là je sais que j'ai tout connu mais
quand quand je suis allé chez chirac ou
chez sarkozy tout ça qu'ils étaient des
hommes assez remarquable voilà même
avant hobbit est rangé encore très vite
et roxanne syndicaux si vous voyez dire
pour décrocher
mais non j'étais toujours heureux de les
rencontrer on apprend toujours des
choses et moi d'y aller là dedans
j'étais très fier d'être invité dans la
dictature de g2j vers des noms n'a pas
droit d'avoir des amis on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir des convictions n'a pas droit d
assumer moi je trouve qu'au contraire
bernard est très courageux je vous
rappelle que quand même ici il a été
dégagé parce qu'il a été comptabilisé
pour être amis de oui c'est vrai on a
droit d'avoir des amis on a droit de les
aimer on a droit d'apporter notre
soutien enfin voilà donc je voulais que
ça s'arrête et où est le mal gilles
jamais tu vois ma tartine bouche km tout
c'est insupportable vous ne croyez pas à
monsieur benjamin sur le tweet je suis
désolé mais moi ce qui me gêne vraiment
beaucoup ces convois bernard à son passé
d'animateur de l'émission légère et qu
on sous-entend qu'il n'est pas cultivée
qui des bêtes qu'il a rien à faire a
laissé des taxes a tué sa fille bien
fait remaquer
nul des recettes on a pas à dire il
comprend pas je voudrais jamais le
rendez vous à l'épreuve de deux nations
fallait voir un orthophoniste je veux
redire que je vais dire je trouve que le
premier tweet ou en bois bernard à sa
sont animés d'un jeu les d'un jeu léger
voilà c'est une façon de faire du
racisme que culturel
on
revoit bernard montiel sa situation
d'animateurs léger d'une démission
légère c'est le cas d'accor était donc
ça veut dire que l'issue est une
émission légère on n'a pas le droit de
s'exprimer sur un homme un avis
politique on a peur d'aller à l'elysée
et ça c'est du racisme social effective
on sait d'où il de faire ça s'avère
assez pour garder les prisons pour la
structure et parce que c'est un
animateur et qu'effectivement moi je
conduis pas de quelqu'un vous avait
présenté une merde ces mêmes qui ont dit
à l'époque de syrie doit fixer bien
faire de politique il a pas sa place
c'est la mine le système social voilà et
ça c'est naze giuly
ouvert
on avait la charge cette jeune militante
voilà qui a été insulté et de la pire
des manières il faut bien dire
d'ailleurs moi je m'étonne que marine
schiappa qui à chaque fois bondi n'a pas
réagi attendant justement pour condamner
la défaite s'est envolé mais mais mais
très très clairement le racisme social
dont vous parlez c'est le peuple
français qui en souffrent quand les
pseudos élites doit starlette leur dise
qui voter mais c'est l'ordinaire des
crétins parce qu'il me faisait tout ce
qui s'est passé
par nantes est un abruti qui prône de la
merde non le qui n'est pas sa
seule vision durable qui recule les
coutures c'est ça le très
connu à rennes c'était qu'a commencé mon
ami
mais c'est elle qui a commencé un art
montiel j'aurais pas répondu être vous
avez pas dix ans si on n'est pas dans la
cour de récré et à 10 sinon c'est si ça
m'amuse et de répondre mais après j'ai
géré lui je me dis dit vetcho net je
vous dis j'ai regretté je lis je suis
pas sélectionné si tu es honnête
jusqu'au bout c'est parce que tu as vu
que les gens ils étaient en train de
saluer tous si j'en passe je te promets
que non je pense que sitôt net normalisé
très vigilant et 60 a vu que tu es en
train de te faire fumer parce que tu
m'as tout commence est facho pas du tout
d'ailleurs c'est bien ce que je vais te
dire je viens tu as net jusqu'au un
orage voiture que j'ai rien contre le
fait que tu as à l'elysée c'est juste
que mais je suis conne elle peut être
que tu te dis tu dis je comprends que
j'avais du mal nantes a demandé de
t'excuser t'es foutu de sa gueule bon
moi je moi je pense que tu t'en fous
mais il devrait pas s'excuser ça lui a
demandé fallait dire non je m'excuse par
la paf juillet si si
le mépris de classe 2 mais at-on
vraiment vraiment toi toi tu toi ça te
dérange pas que c'était moi qui l'aï là
bas ils sont entre eux sont bien y'a pas
de mixité il n'y a pas de diversité sont
tous beaux dans leurs costards pays
viennent bosser gratos c'est bien c'est
nous je sais quoi il n'y avait pas de
beauf qui fait kiffer regardez bien
l'image regardé gagner là il n'ya rien
n'y a pas de si vous êtes entre vous la
savez tous entre eux roulent à 50 60 ans
entre nécessaire les foulards hills
alors
[Rires]
ils ont gagné ils sont contents ils ont
gagné un truc qu'ils en gagnent s comme
je suis une finale de foot y'en a qui
gagnent les outils pleurait naquirent
quatre
mois moi je suis bien ça me dérange pas
c'est la culture c'est chez nous ça
c'est la france c'est l'elysée c'est
beau c'est bon après j'aurais voulu voir
plus de diversité dans les invités de ce
que je vois que tu as dit c'est quoi la
caméra mais je vois des têtes
complètement cramé sait pas on
pousse est là bas en bas à gauche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien compris la reddition du
mieux lavez votre amie estelle mossely
s'écoute sportifs y avait plein de gens
c'est un aspect qu'on dit il et pierre
bellanger annoncé hier qu'il l'a déjà
fait il ya 110 ans
mais si tu rien n'avait pas mais on a
dit en plus qu'il était pas obligé de le
faire parce qu'il l'a déjà fait il ya
cinq ans donc il va en refaire une autre
c'est comme ça cela dit c'est la
démocratie qui oblige il sait très bien
ce regard des
comptes est content
c'est un quinté plus
[Musique]
est-ce que vous la raconte y est d'y
aller genre vous aviez des gens
téléphonent non là je peux pas te parler
je vais à l'investiture des manuels
jamais évident a rétabli la vérité qu'il
aime vraiment comme il y en avoir et
daniel non mais bernard non
je préfère lui qui bossent ouais ça
qu'est ce que tu as dit toi de dire
ouais moi j'ai pas envie d'y aller parce
qu'attention mon image j'ai dit je me
fais comme il y avait des publics savoir
lui qui assume plutôt que les artistes
et les contre issa faye d'hypocrites je
vais pas y aller parce que j'ai pas
envie qu'on dise à un temps qu'on passe
et chevron moi je préfère les mecs comme
lui qui
n'est pas derrière donc moi je m'en tape
je vais te dire ça c'est pas tout le
temps je la télé alors maintenant il ya
des connards qui ont dit aussi c'est un
mot à moi c'est vrai qu'ils ont dit
aussi que j'étais à la télévision grâce
au maquereau je suis désolé ça fait 38
ans que cela dit et ils se mêlent
j'avais pas n'était pas n'en était pas
non vous n'êtes ni en 85 c d'un gros
mais il s'est renseigné et en plus c'est
son anniversaire qui est passé de 3
jours
mais crosby mais vous qui me bouffe et
le thon
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
rouge il est chaud des chiots sinon je
suis désolé
j'aimerais que ça se termine bien qu'est
ce que vous avez dit je suis désolée
auprès de ces mois son prénom pardon
mary j mario jean marie émilie marelli
je suis désolé d'arles et j'ai retiré ce
tweet non pas sous la menace c'est que
c'est pas mon style je ne fais jamais je
ne réponds jamais je n'ai relevé parce
que c'est débile en revanche quand elle
a remis une couche est lui aussi un bon
aujourd'hui les laisser tu vois c'est
bon c'est pas grave je vous en veux pas
je sais que vous êtes dans la défaite
c'est quoi
je regrette une chose je regrette une
chose parce que le pq des procès de vous
avoir comparé à du pq oui et pâques
l'afp kassim à dire parce que le pécule
c'est do with et moelleux et c'est
hygiénique
passé
à merci en tout cas à vous 2 1 c'est
sympa
m